welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Anna Maria Ibanez a professor and
former dean of the School of Economics
at the Universidad de los Andes she is
at Yale as a rice visiting professor and
senior fellow at the Macmillan Center
professor Yvonne uses research studies
the economic consequences of internal
conflict in particular the costs of war
and conflict on the civilian population
today we'll talk with professor
amamiya's about the 52-year war in
colombia the peace process which has
just begun and the post-conflict
challenges it may face welcome welcome
professor Ibanez thanks Marilyn for the
invitation
let's begin with a kind of an overview
of the situation in Colombia today we
are in very interesting and exciting
times right now in Colombia after 52
years of conflict the national
government and FARC the the oldest and
largest khadija group in colombia signed
peace this this Monday besides a
committing on the demobilization
disarmament and reintegration to
civilian life the Peace Accords have
provisions for promoting access to rural
land and Rural Development a promoting
participation political participation
from former combatants eradicating
illicit trade drug trade and also
restitution victims as well as creating
a transitional justice tribunal you know
so it's big challenges ahead in math
challenges ahead and we are hopeful but
we also know that the challenges are big
and that we need to prepare for them how
did the peace talks come about it has
been a really long process although the
war has been on for 52 years he'd really
intensified during the 90s
due to illicit drug funds basically the
illicit drug funds intensified the
conflict and amplified it throughout the
geographical territory and the worst
years of conflicts when where in 2001
2002 2003 by that time each year we had
around 400,000 internally displaced
persons and parallel to this
intensification of the conflict what we
had is that the government invested huge
resources to strengthen the military
forces the US government supported that
process through monetary resources but
more importantly so through intelligence
and technical support so starting around
2006 the the government the national
government and the military forces were
able to exert Millett a major military
blows to the Girija so they were
isolated again in their traditional
strongholds and that I think said the
incentives for styling the peace talks
but we have been in peace talks for many
years in the 1990s the md80 maryam/mary
a group another Girija groups
immobilized in 2006 the paramilitary
groups to mobilize and now FARC follow
suit so we have been in a almost like a
third 30 year process of trying to
broker please okay
you mentioned internally displaced
people and it's a mind-boggling figure
15 percent of the population correct and
when you say internally displaced
internally they were displaced in other
areas of the country or they left the
country
no it's most is internal displacement is
within the geographical borders of
Colombia so the seven point four million
people does not include refugees but
mostly it was internally displaced
people going from rural areas of the
country to earth-2 they were urban areas
of the country because of the of the war
and the intense violence against the
civilian population I see okay and now
that peace has been brokered what will
what will happen to these people will
they be able to simply go back to their
home towns or
it doesn't seem to be that it would be
that easy since the word has been going
on for so long I think that most of
internally displaced persons will will
prefer to stay in there in urban areas
in some research that we have done
applying surveys to internally displaced
households they say they express that
they only 11 percent will be willing to
return to their to their hometowns I
expect that will change as violence
eases and as land starts being wasted to
the to the to the displaced population
but most of them will continue in the
urban areas what we have found in this
study is that for example female-headed
households are not willing to return
they prefer to stay in urban areas with
where health and education services are
larger and are of better quality we also
found that people that were heavily
traumatized before displacement are not
willing to return so mostly the people
who will return they are formal
landowners and agricultural workers but
let's say it's about 30% it would be
anyways 2 million people so it's going
to be a big challenge to to promote the
return of 30% of the population and the
government would have to provide support
for the return return process but also
to create income generation
opportunities to restitute land to
insert them again into the social
networks that they used to have in the
in their hometown so it's it's a big
challenge as well yes yes you had
mentioned the drug trade and I imagine
you mean cocaine specifically and that
had been such a big influence on the
conflict do you do you think that will
not rear its head again how will how
will Colombia keep that at bay cocaine
trade will continue ok even after the
conflict ends a cocaine trade is not a
cause of conflict but is basically it
has helped the country the conflict to
intensify and to amplify it throughout
the geographical territory cocaine train
is mostly
because it is illegal trade it has huge
profits for the people that participate
in illegal trade and it's also the cause
of a very illed designed policy
international policy to combat illegal
trade so that will continue after the
piece ends - - how illegal trade is
going - we really need an international
policy to change the the so-called war
on drugs has had immense cost for the
Colombian population a lot of people
have died and it has been vastly
ineffective so a study that was done by
Pasquale Restrepo and Sandra Russo -
Colombian economists show that to
eradicate one hectare of coca you have
to fumigate 30 hectares of coca so you
see how vastly ineffective it has been
so we hope that it will change but I'm
not very optimistic that that will
happen
mm-hmm do you foresee any change in the
the politics of the country in terms of
who is running the country that kind of
thing with the peace process moving
forward I don't anticipate that would
happen
hey FARC are not very popular they were
a very aggressive a guerrilla movement
they killed and victimized a very large
percentage of the population they might
be able to get elected in local
elections of the people of the places
where they were strong and that's very
isolated regions of the country but I
really don't anticipate that we will
have a shift for example to a leftist
movement in power in Colombia I think
there is a long way ahead one of the
consequences of the conflict in Colombia
the long conflict in Colombia is that
the population is very right-winged okay
so I think that's not very easy now an
election is coming up next week correct
in Colombia and the election is too what
will the election decide or a vote it's
always about the 2nd of October okay and
it's a plebiscite and the president was
not legally binded to call for a
plebiscite to support or not support
quartz but he decided he wanted to
submit the accords to the to the will of
the people so the purpose of the plan
aside is to say whether the population
is going to support or not the the peace
accord that was negotiated with with
FARC it's not a referendum it only has
only 13 percent of the registered to
vote population have to vote the
plebiscite in order to be effective but
it's an important and it's an important
process because a the president needs
the popular support sure sure and it
kind of legitimizes the what he's done
when do you anticipate any issues with
the vote well the country now it's
extremely polarized because of this
process a former president Uribe is
against the peace process he is
campaigning against the peace process so
there's going to be the polls showed
that there's going to be around twenty
to thirty percent of people not
supporting the peace process but I think
the main risk is that we don't reach the
threshold that the plebiscites need in
order to be effective and what happens
if the people don't support you know
what will happen at that point it's it's
completely crazy because a basically
doesn't it's not legally binding so the
president would be able to continue with
the peace process and the peace accord
can be implemented but basically what
would happen is that he will lose the
popular support to continue with the
peace process but that doesn't mean
necessarily that the peace process is
going to fold mm-hmm so it's gonna be a
very interesting few weeks coming up I
would say it's interesting and it's in
stressing yes because the population is
very polarized so so what are going to
be some of the biggest challenges in the
event that the the peace conflict moves
forward I mean the peace the peace
process works
and is moving forward what are some of
the biggest challenges do you think well
there are several several challenges
first
once the Peace Accords are
approved through the police I twitch I
hope it will happen it will just be the
first step that doesn't mean that we
will be in peace it will take several
decades the first one is that the peace
accord is ambitious and it has to be
implemented by a state that has been
weak in the first place so a the first
important challenge is to strength the
Colombian state which is not going to be
an easy task a second challenge that I
think is important is that we are
undergoing through fiscal pressures
because the we depended heavily on oil
prices and the oil prices dropped so
fiscal resources are lower
at this time sure another important
challenge is that a that we will have I
mean the political participation is
going to be difficult we had a peace
process in the 90s in 1980s with FARC it
didn't it was not successful and it was
not successful because many of the of
the people of the park that were
participating in politics were
assassinated so it might well be the
case that the paramilitary groups are
still around in the country may try to
destabilize the situation we are Satan
aiding the political representatives of
the FARC is there any indication that
that is something that could possibly
happen there are indications during the
last year's around 60 60 community
leaders have been assassinated and these
are leaders that have been pushing for
land restitution for example so the the
risk is there and I think that's that's
a minke big challenge that's an
immediate challenge that the government
has to face on how to guarantee the life
of the people that are demobilizing and
that's important now I know the vote is
coming up but is there any indication
prior to the vote that the population is
supporting this piece a supporting piece
want to move in that direction are tired
of the conflict well you have the polls
and also it there is a process of the
civic of the population doing a lot of
demonstrations especially young people
who are
going out and showing the support to the
peace process and it has been massive in
some cases a lot of demonstration
marches going to the public spaces to
show support artistical things and but
but I think the vote may turn out to be
low and the number of people voting
might be low are they would they be
afraid to come out to vote and it's the
same similar with the demonstrating with
demonstrations are people afraid to come
out and demonstrate or vote no there's
no backlash no for doing that not for
demonstrating there there are not
backlashes for that most of the
demonstrations are in large urban cities
in Colombia and you're done you really
don't have the presence of these illegal
armed groups in in the urban areas as
strong as in in more rural areas so
there is no backlashes for that the
backlashes and the the violence is
mostly in the rural rural areas where
the armed groups are present and when
some military and drug dealers are still
present who who benefit who benefit from
war and who would prefer that the work
continues so what do you think the
future holds for colombia well I'm
hopeful ma I am from Colombia and I live
there but we have a big task ahead yeah
I hope that the first years of after the
peace agreement that has just been side
are going to be difficult are going to
be risky we have to ensure that violence
is not going to erupt again we have to
protect a former companions of FARC so
we don't have assassination political
assassinations and we really have to
protect all these process a so I'm
optimistic but I really think that the
risk and the challenges of of conflict
reverting again are still high there are
other two groups that have not
demobilized it vln which is a smaller
guerrilla group and criminal bands that
were former paramilitary groups there
are still act
if they are still present throughout the
territory so we still have a few steps
really to reach peace but I'm very
hopeful very very good it is important I
think to remain hopeful and to keep
trying of course yes
thank you so much for being here today
and sharing some of your work Thank You
Marilyn for the invitation for more
information about Professor Ibanez and
her research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale